the Euro max highlights and Uzi roast
Carlos Makani that's right we have this
week's euro Mac highlights just for you
coming up during the next half hour so
please take your seats get comfortable
and get ready for some very interesting
European cultural news updates here we
go all alone why many young Germans are
remaining single alpine retreat a luxury
hotel in Bavaria and its famous concert
down below an underground lake in
Switzerland is a hit with tourists in
recent months the German media have been
publishing reports related to young
people and their inability to maintain
long lasting relationships author
Michael Nast has written a book on the
topic and for months now he's been
promoting it even though the book has
been selling well it has been met with
widespread criticism by experts who say
it oversimplifies a very complex matter
let's take a look at today's first
report and you can go ahead and just
judge for yourself author Mitchell Nast
is giving a talk at the University of
Kiel it's the 61st stop on his book tour
and around 800 people have come to hear
him read from his bestseller Jenna hats
on but seems unfazed about a
commitment-phobic generation the book
has topped the German nonfiction charts
for months in anecdotes Nast writes
about the complicated love lives of
singles between the ages of 20 and 40
know and then you can recognize yourself
to degree in satires like this it really
makes you think whether you recognize
yourself or not you just can't escape it
because it surrounds you every day
Mikael Nast was born in Berlin before he
started writing he worked in advertising
in 2015 he penned an online column
describing the commitment shy generation
why the text struck a chord and received
over a million clicks within a matter of
days the idea for the book was born I
described the sensibilities of people
have considered incapable of commitment
by either themselves or those around
them there appears to be a needful
material like this I don't pretend to be
an expert and I don't dispense advice I
take a literary approach to create an
authentic image of life
Nast uses stories from his circle of
friends in Berlin to describe the
current attitude towards relationships
he tries to capture the love life of the
younger generation in sentences such as
we want to eternal devotion and self
surrender but despair when we realize
that life rarely resembles the movies
Nast believes that young Germans love
lives have also changed because of the
proliferation of online dating sites and
dating apps they expand the pool of
potential partners and raise the bar the
problem is that ultimately we've
conformed so well to our consumer
society that we approach interpersonal
relationships like consumers that the
dating apps are a good example they're
set up like online shops so we use the
same principles to go about choosing a
partner as we do a product lisa Fishbach
works as a couple's psychologist for
elite partner one of the largest online
dating sites in Germany it conducts
studies into the lives of singles
including whether they're incapable of
committing the desire to have a lifelong
partner remains unchanged we find that
again and again in our surveys 90% of
people want someone to be their one and
only forever after that's the romantic
ideal but the reality looks quite
different as the tolerance for
frustration has fallen and with it the
staying power to suffer through phases
in which things aren't going so well so
the readiness to leave a relationship
has increased relationships have grown
more unstable because there's less
willingness to invest in solving
problems Fishbach says the Millennials
should really be described as unwilling
rather than unable to commit and she
thinks that's due to their tireless
quest for the picture-perfect life
we're no longer looking for a suitable
partner to have a happy relationship
with instead we're looking for the best
partner for a perfect relationship
that means we're also shoving the entire
responsibility on to the other party
they must ensure that the relationship
works perfectly social scientist
Christine Schmidt says the way in which
the younger generation conducts its
relationships can be traced back to the
social changes of the last 40 years men
no longer tend to be the sole
breadwinners with wives who are
economically dependent on them couples
split up more quickly but that doesn't
mean that love and relationships are a
thing of the past what we're seeing is
that the phases in which people live
alone are becoming more frequent and
these phases are becoming increasingly
socially acceptable that's the biggest
change but I very much doubt that an
entire generation is incapable of
forming relationships back in Kiel even
if the experts don't think
commitment-phobic is the right way to
describe the love life of many young
Germans it makes for a catchy headline
people see themselves in the book they
identify strongly with the material and
interestingly they use it as a means to
reflect upon themselves to get some
distance a look at life from a different
perspective and to look at what isn't
working out right you could accuse
Michelle Nast of generalizing the
experiences of young people living in
Berlin a very tiny sample of the
population but his books appeal is broad
it's already sold 140,000 copies across
Germany
let's move on to one of Europe's
underground attractions we head towards
a disused salt mine near the Polish city
of Cracow salt in its heyday was a
highly valuable commodity and the mine
we are about to see brought significant
wealth to the region however since it
was declared a UNESCO World Heritage
Heritage Site in 1978 it is once again
providing wealth to the area but this
time because it has become one of the
region's top tourist attractions a world
deep below the surface with its own
Chapel a spa and a mining workshop for
tourists we've come to the former
village cos salt mine for seven
centuries table salt was mined here
today it's a unesco world heritage site
with around 1 million tourists every
year student so i know perfectly what is
inside so expectations be I can't
recommend it by not for my friends so
yeah it says go there are two ways to
descend into this underworld you can
take the stairs or if you're in a hurry
there's the elevator
the minds nine levels lie between 64
meters and 135 meters below the surface
more than two thousand chambers were
created by the mining process now you'll
find fascinating items such as
sculptures made of rock salt carved by
the miners
after walking around for an hour through
the tunnels and chambers visitors will
come upon the minds greatest attraction
the Chapel of st. kinga built around
1895 110 metres below the surface
usually 3/4 - the IT every year because
of different accidents so miners wanted
to have places to pray that's why they
carved chapels and that's why in chapels
they carved religious figures religious
services are held regularly in the king
a chapel and couples can even get
married underground if they donate at
least 1,100 euros
during their tour this choir was
inspired to sing
the chapel has become famous for its
acoustics and for its many details such
as chandeliers made of rock salt you
don't have like this place in Indonesia
so this is very amazing for us you know
even though for me myself I come for the
few times but my still impressed with
this place this is very beautiful to
think that people came here and works on
a daily basis for hundreds and hundreds
of years is quite like mind-blowing
isn't it
visitors can also experience how it
might have felt to work in a salt mine
by taking a different tour going on the
authentic miners route requires
professional equipment and some physical
strength is needed to extract the rock
salt this tour is very interesting you
can learn how things used to be here but
it's not just tourists who come to the
village a salt mine a below-ground
health resort promises relief for people
who suffer from chronic respiratory
illnesses such as asthma or certain
allergies the clinic 135 metres
underground is a unique spa location
offering an especially beneficial
microclimate it is the high relative
humidity stable constant temperature and
high concentration of natural fluoride
in the
the air is free for any pollutants which
are abandoned on the surface and from
allergens like pollen and other parts
small particles and anyone who hasn't
had enough after a 3-hour tour can even
sleep here overnight stays are the
latest attraction in village
musical heritage is a very important
element to the Schloss Alma hotels
history and existence it is located in
the German Alps some 100 kilometers
south of Munich more than 200 concerts
are performed here every year mostly by
solo artists chamber musicians and jazz
musicians there is definitely something
quite special and enchanting about this
place so let's learn a little more about
this hotel's history and the cultural
significance in our next report Slav
Alma lies at the foot of the vetter
Stein mountains in the German Alps the
landscape is stunning and the Hotel
Majestic it's also a popular venue for
many of the world's greatest musicians
just in most toys Elmo is my absolute
favorite place I've traveled a lot too
with my family too still for me and my
children this place remains a dream meet
human Kingdom I'm calm art-lete psyche
loved
understa Lucas and time passes
differently here the air is different
it's a world of its own Elmo exerts such
a magical attraction that top musicians
are happy to accept the hotels offer
play for free in exchange for a few days
stay with their families just the chance
to be surrounded by so much natural
beauty it gives you a kind of a space to
enjoy music in an unpressurized ik and
so we actually always find the right
concentration the right creativity here
in el mao so we just we are just looking
for this the whole year and when we
finally get it it's wonderful small
Selma plays host to over 200 concerts
every year most of them solo
performances chamber music and jazz
kundo miss y'all said bail I do wonder
why it's so magical I think it's because
everything fits the dimensions the
location and you probably feel all the
history to support monastic assisted and
life loss Alma was built by philosopher
and Protestant theologian johannes
miller and completed in 1916 he wanted
it to be a place where people would
transcend their egos and behold the
beauty of the surroundings back then
there were already around a hundred
cultural events a year by the 1950s jaws
Alma was attracting artists such as the
Amadeus Cortez and Yehudi Menuhin
they're rich and varied arts program
complements the luxury and the natural
beauty there is certainly no shortage of
eager artists become a few spoonful and
Ponte I received four or five hundred
inquiries every day many are incredibly
interesting unfounded unkind and my
heart breaks when I have to turn them
down for technical reasons or because
there's no available date all some
ensembles are just too big for the place
it's a course into this house the
festivities to mark the first century of
schloss Elmo what else
what music how about a walking tour or
some scuba diving inside a cave or maybe
you'd prefer enjoying a musical
performance and a glass of local wine by
an underground lake well all these are
within your reach at the Saint Leo nard
underground lake which is located in the
canton of belies in switzerland it is
the largest natural underground lake
known in europe if it sounds like an
amazing place to visit that's because it
is but don't just take my word for it in
our next report we get to see all the
images rainbow trout are the only
inhabitants of the biggest natural
subterranean lake in Europe they were
brought here especially to the lake
under the small Swiss village of san
Leona both to maintain the water quality
and also as an extra attraction for
tourists
say the leaks a vo regularly guides
visitors across the lake he is
fascinated by the calm although the moon
we live in a world where we're trying to
get closer to nature to return to the
essential things of life this is a place
where we can be more at one with nature
away from the outside world and all the
excitement the subterranean Lake is 300
meters long and 20 meters wide behind
the rock formation is a cave that
stretches for over a kilometer but it's
not accessible the light projections
allude to an old legend according to
which the girls of San Liana would come
here to see the faces of the future
husbands reflected in the water
now the lake attracts some 80 thousand
visitors a year the ceilings have been
strengthened to prevent pieces of rock
from falling on them on the command
console security you feel very safe here
and the water has an incredible energy
it's so clear there's a fabulous feeling
of safety you can feel the resonance of
the caves energy it's fabulous really
fabulous to know the stories from him
how it is created I know yeah I just
like how the nature is formed and why
suddenly here diving and swimming are
usually banned here but sometimes
exceptions are made these professional
divers brave the temperatures of 10
degrees Celsius the wrecks at the bottom
of the lake were installed by Savio and
his team as a surprise at the end of the
tour
the cave has a constant temperature of
15 degrees Celsius perfect for storing
wine this one was made by Christophe
Beck lessee the winemaker has a vineyard
70 metres above the lake an ideal
location sample don t put the vanilla
beans the conditions are very good for
making wine many visitors get to see
that there are people making wine and
that's very important so people will
talk about what we're doing is important
before them people the pop are empty but
not much if the locals here were always
aware of this water filled cave but it
was only in the 1940s that it became
more accessible following an earthquake
all of a sudden the small quiet village
of San lien are attracted a lot of
unfamiliar attention
the economy Paulo village it's
definitely a plus for the village dozens
of jobs have been created by the lake
and in economic benefits for restaurants
hotels and businesses across the region
hola hi Joe every year around a dozen
concerts are held in the cave tonight
there are about 100 people in the
audience on stage are the two a full
country and blues band from Lausanne the
musicians have toured the world but
they've never played on such an unusual
stage before it's magical there's an
incredible silence I think the audience
feels it too so there was silence in
some pieces and that changed our way of
playing it gave us the space to play
with the silence and that was impressive
we also see since the fall of the wall
and German unification Berlin has been
continually redefining itself as the
nation's capital the city is
experiencing a construction boom that
doesn't look like it'll slow down
anytime soon new buildings and stylish
apartment complexes are popping up even
in areas of former East Berlin that most
people would not go near we visited one
such development located near an old
prison which has now been converted into
luxury homes
this is artists village a series of
designer townhouses on the edge of
Berlin the homes are located on the
water with bike pads right at the
doorstep but this tranquil landscape has
a dark side for 113 years it was home to
a prison complex which closed in 1990
since then a new generation has moved in
hello hi I'm Marcus come on in and take
a look around the townhouse is 240
square meters over five stories the loft
is the masterpiece
as the Sun the 90 Mahalo the special
feature of the house is the loft on the
third floor
the room is five and a half meters high
and there's a great view of the water
and we like coming up here to watch TV
or we just sit down and enjoy the view
the him that I've been making east
the loft is also where the family likes
to entertain
a kitchen was built discreetly into the
wall three meter high doors open to
reveal a fully stocked minibar Marcus
and his wife also an architect were
involved in the layout of their home
from the start in 2006 film is mine
spider looping so mmm good boy this is
my second favorite part of the house
roof is a great place to get away from
it all
we came up with the idea of opening it
up by including these windows and you
can push them open and stuff
demonic face so often cotton the town
house is just a 15-minute drive from
downtown moving on now to the second
floor this is the etosha Octavia this
floor includes our bedroom and bathroom
the needy but at the two end when the
doors are opened a more or less
disappear into the wall open-plan effect
they're often Marcus and his wife made
the decision to limit the use of color
in their home keeping it in line with
the general gray black and white design
splashes of color can be found in small
details like pictures on the wall here
we are on the first floor our daughter
has her room here like no there's also a
guest room this floor has lots of small
rooms so we designed the hallway with
cupboard doors that gives you the
feeling that you're standing inside a
coverage after then you open the doors
if I'm ahead you can see the rooms and
the guest bathroom fmz the doors
throughout the entire house were
specially designed to maintain the
feeling of openness here in the kitchen
on the ground floor the sliding door is
also a multifunctional serving as a wall
and chalkboard
as a quantity done via taped off
environment we wanted to create open
space I won't come in you have the large
hallway you then go through the kitchen
it goes achieve it to a gang about but
we wanted to be able to close off the
kitchen so we included this large
sliding door so you can close it the
kitchen opens on to a 75 square metre
garden with a view of the former prison
complex when we first moved here there
were just sandy spaces and the old
prison and two years later the prison
was converted into apartments and now
they're all occupied onto the hope of
one
so the phone the hunt was our berlin
waterside home thanks for coming by and
stop by again soon
I'm afraid we have run out of time I'd
like to thank you all for tuning in and
allowing me to share this half hour with
you remember to follow us and interact
with us on social media all right my
friends it's time to go hope to see you
all very very soon take care and have a
good one